taste buds they come to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools going to
fight but only one food can be right
taste
buds hello taste buddies it's time for t
a s t e buds Joe you look different
today I got
fatter and I got
lasic basic and lasic baby uh I'm
sitting in for the famous Joe do roza
this is Joe G Joe do roza is on um he's
on on a roundabout let me hold on you
are you don't [__] get that salt is
better than Pepper I don't know what the
[__] you're a
idiot is that better so everybody tuning
in is
get all right so you guys got the you
got this shot that you
needed Scrat scratch that
itch um great it's a different joke
today we have the one and only Jo gado
in studio with us today thank you buddy
for having me yeah appreciate you
co-host to sit in the seat D roza is on
a every once in a while he'll do like a
little uh a drive to wherever he wants
like like I don't even know if he plans
it oh that's awesome um so he just gets
lost Joe just gets the car every in a
while we get an SOS and he comes back a
few weeks later uh no I don't know he's
I guess he's like um either just taking
a time out or like maybe that's amazing
you know that's great good for him yeah
I think he's uh just you know if anybody
needs it I believe I feel like it's Jo
yeah he he could release some pressure
for sure yeah um so he gets in his car
and he just goes to from one place to
the next place I think a couple times
he's done it he drives like cross
country or just wherever yeah and I
think I don't know if he's finding
himself or taking a break or trying to
write and clear as said I think maybe
all a combination of all he might also
he might be devious I know maybe he has
some second life that we don't none of
us know about might
Co fting R
family did the [__] fighting family s up
his children did you uh did you get um
do you get a text that goes hey it's
time it's that time of the year and then
he just goes well how does that how's
that information presented to you no no
he he's he's like oh you know he just
you know I'm thinking about doing this
on this date yeah and I see the string
hanging there are we going to have
people outside the window you think have
you seen or heard anybody
yet oh why they come out they you have
like Spider-Man this place I I swear to
God man I try to con I come in here and
when we're filming or I'm just working
there's always guys on those platform
ropes just like right outside the window
and they're not washing windows they're
like
Drilling and banging and it's all day
long I'm like this is a work building we
always have to call the management be
like hey there's like a bunch of guys
right outside my window just hammering
into the wall I'm recording something in
here do you ever think it's Spider-Man
like in a battle you're you are in New
York City like honest if one day
Spider-Man was on that thing I don't
know what I would he opens window he
like dude stop complaining I'm fighting
Rhino I would I mean no but it's so
annoying it recall and they they usually
help but then another thing happens go
ahead so I guess a lot of times I'm here
on like a weekday like a Tuesday or a
Wednesday and sometimes I'll come in
just to be completely alone in silence
to write yeah and right across the
street I'm not going to say like where
we are or anything but like right across
the street there's like a park yeah and
they have live
music and it's every single at least
every single Tuesday it's been for the
entire summer and it's a live band it's
across the street it's only you know 50
feet away and it's on huge speakers so I
hear it like it's playing in here and
they play three sets over like the
course of three hours oh man and it's
the same set every week and it's so loud
is it good or bad I'm sure it's fine if
you're like out there listening and they
like oh free music or it's fine if you
like hear it once but it's the same
music every week and it's like it's so
and a lot of the songs are like popular
played out songs so it's like those ones
where you're like if I never heard this
again I'm fine yeah and it's there Sally
deep Cuts you like you like G it's three
hours of this and it's so loud that I
can't escape it and so I had to like get
a mini
speaker my phone up to it and blast
literally white static noise and then I
just hear it lightly underneath and I
work in here when it's like but like 6
hours I'm just he like like the H old
HBO logo like HBO just turned on just
like that it gets me under my skin so
badly like like you know what it is you
can't be put outputting good content
then though you got you got static in
your ears when I can't control something
yeah you got Bad Bunny outside that's
not good no it's nothing like that it's
like
hey so it's like that's a fun old song
but but like not every week and not like
when you're trying to work it's like ah
hey I'm just like like one time I opened
the window and I just shouted but I knew
they weren't going to hear me or
anything but I just was like want to
like get it out that was your version of
Georgia Rose's Drive yeah exactly
screaming no but it's just it's just
terrible and I want to go down there and
just be like yeah why the same music
like get a different band get a band
that'll play other songs right my point
is I walk around a lot and I get
incensed by things that I can't control
that are impeding on I know this a lot
of me managing managing you for a long
time of our life had been me just
talking you down to being like just
making you realize it really doesn't
matter you can't do anything about it so
we talked about this yesterday on your
podcast so you you have a podcast Steve
Burn called Two Cool Moms you've been
doing it for quite a while now now got
yeah did it for a year now we just got
picked up by iHeart so we're part of the
iHeart podcast Network now which I'm
really excited about and you have the
studios up at the ihart building we went
up there you had the whole thing if you
know me I'm a big ihart guy you know
that for Years love those guys always do
that he
serious I did my love a big guy I'm a
big heart guy I'm a big iPhone guy no
but you used to go like on to their
concerts and like like come out on stage
and stuff and help intro them I ended up
in Brazil because I won a contest back
in 2001 me and Joe Fish went down to Rio
De Janeiro yeah you went to Carnival
carnal which is by the way I know you
yeah very well and I know that you'll
you'll I mean that's in one aspect oh
it's all you you're going to run wild
down there you're going to party like
they're going to have to keep up with
you like it's the perfect level of
intensity and partying for you but on
the flip side you don't drink you don't
do drugs I don't speak Portuguese you
don't speak Portuguese there a lot of a
lot of things stacked against me yeah
and you don't and and so and down there
also uh correct me if I'm wrong as as
many good things as there are there's
also some seediness down especially in
and around that event there's a lot of
what what have you pickpocketing
stealing of kidneys and whatnot yeah
knives and exposed knives and you went
with the only other bu me and Joe me and
Joe Fish yeah yeah and uh and what was
that like was it was it like what was
the craziest or funest thing you do did
or saw and what was like did you ever by
any chance to find yourself like being
tailed well yeah we did the the
concierge at the hotel told us like uh
Joe Fish had to buy a shirt because when
our friend Joe he's a good guy he just
doesn't pack yeah we call him Joe Fish
or Joe the fish he shows yeah he he does
aquarium design he's like a marine
biologist yeah he's like he does for he
does he he cornered the market on New
York uh aquarium design and also Imports
of corals which is true like you can't
get any Coral that you see here in
America States and now rocks Joe Fish
does they come through him through
California rocks pin what you gonna say
hold it once Split Second just to give
you a little update on Joe Fish young
guy great guy loved he worked at a fish
store a pet store loved fish yeah he
then got a degree in fish Marine bi and
then he started to um install customade
fish F tanks and do the upkeep on them
in residential homes and businesses it
kept growing and growing and his skill
set kept growing and knowledge and then
he started to make these aquariums in
like hotels and rich people's homes
celebrity homes that like Tracy Morgan
gandal
Trac he got sharks he got sharks for
Tracy Morgan he's still very friends
with good friends with Morgan he was
about to before like months before
gandini passed they were talking about
opening a retail chain together he was
going to open up and it was really cool
is he's a close he's played us the like
messages that James gandini left on his
SW like I hear the messages yeah awes
and I told him he asked me to name it
I's like what am I going to name I was
you got to name it sleep with the fishes
and I was going right for the retail
spot yeah and they were they were like
literally working it all out it was
crazy oh God that's so good yeah and uh
it was crazy and you had to see the
stuff he put in it was like stuff like
in the magazines like yeah has he ever
waited on you keeping a dead fish in
your freezer has he I don't know if he
has I don't think he'd be for it I don't
think he'd be for it this might he might
get might get
because me and Joe Fish we were
roommates for 2 years we lived together
in Queens and he I was like all right we
got to get an aquarium and he's like oh
dude I got to I don't want to get an
aquarium because like I have an aquarium
here now I was like bringing your work
home with you I'm like your Joe Fish
it's part of the it's part of the mque
we had that huge aquarium and every fish
in all Tank died and I'm like how are
you in
business yeah but then he got like he
gets hired to do like part like crazy
parties yeah like so when they're doing
like you know I don't like for example
like ComicCon right yeah like if some
like shark NATO or something
him he went there and he brought sharks
he transported them in Chambers in a in
I saw it he opened his truck and there
was like you know two three foot lemon
shars imagine yeah imagine like uh you
know dog carriers but they clear acrylic
things and Sh and he just pulls out and
Carries sharks yeah yeah and so he he
became known as this guy and then he
became a huge mult like a big big
business guy big business guy and so
he's Joe the fish and you know
coincidentally his twin brother he's he
does beat the butterflies he does
butterflies yeah he he catches and cure
and like mounts and dos butter butterfly
design exotic butterflies in frames and
stuff like that we got to get him on the
show we should get both of them on here
he's one of the most interest his
brother won't come on but where is he
living Jo in Cali yeah yeah but when hea
it he'll come on he has stories for days
he does yeah he's great and he's he's
just such a character so you were with
him at Carnival in Brazil yeah so where
the conier tells us don't go shout out
Joe Fish so Joe Fish forgot his forgot a
shirt because he famously like we went
to Puerto Rico I'm not kidding he opened
up his thing he had a pair of trunks
pair of shorts a snorkel and a football
and two pairs of socks in his and we
were going to Puerto Rico for four days
and I said what are you doing and he
goes I'll just go shopping yeah he
always did it he's always like I got to
take a run out and get some stuff so he
ran so we he we had to run to the mall
and the con is like oh it's on the other
side of this uh overpass he's like but
I'll call you a taxi and we're like oh
it's we'll just walk he goes don't walk
the guy's like don't he's like don't
walk under there he's like people wait
for you and we're like what he's like
yeah he's like bad people wait for you
and that's like his English was like
kind of broken that's what he said and
we're like okay so we took a cab and as
we're driving through I swear oh my
mother we saw a dude just standing with
like a straight up like Rambo knife in
the shadows like leaning waiting for
somebody to walk through and I was like
he's like and then we came back and I
said there's a guy there he goes yeah
they're there all the time and he's like
yeah they just stop Shoppers who walk
back they take their knife out they take
their bags and they go is that crazy wow
yeah so it was pretty bad but uh we you
know we we had ramble nice over the top
too it was a full-blown Ram I feel like
they could have just a regular pocket
knife but I don't know I think that's a
statement I think if somebody has a
switchblade you could be like all right
are we going to mix it up what are we
going to do butterfly knife that's too
much it's too much Dramatics involved
it's a butter knife you're taking them
out but a rainbow knife is a statement
it's like it's like that in a sword yeah
yeah yeah the next thing is a sword
right of for Rambo night I watched Rambo
I watched the trail of Rambo the other
night oh okay well that's that's almost
the same
thing I did I did a like a like a like a
bomb edible mhm and uh the only time I
had to to myself now it's between like
10:00 and midnight yeah and um I'm in
the living room and like you know
everyone else is sleeping yeah and uh
that's how it works that's how it works
and I'm just like I sometimes I'll just
sit there even though like I I get to
bed by 1200 I'm in bed by 10 to 1200 but
some nights if I'm feeling like I want a
party I'll just stay up from 10 to 12
things get crazy I realized the other
day that like it's the only time in my
day in my life any moment that I can
feel like it's my old life ah like you
know it's cuz I I always sat down at the
end of the night watch TV by myself
you're known for that and like but like
now everything so fast and moving so
fast and when I sit down and and and
there's no one with me and I actually
can have the a moment to watch a
television I'm like oh it's different
pretend like it's like 10 years ago it's
different because it's not like the road
where you could do that in a hotel room
you're in your own environment so it's
completely different it's rare and uh
and so I was like let me watch I'm going
to so I have I made a wish list made a
wish list on Apple TV you can make a
wish list and I did it a long time ago
it's all movies from like the 40s to now
that I like either never saw that
Classics or I want to watch again or
whatever it is and so every time I want
to you know I go through that and I
could never ever commit and so the other
night I I I was like my rule is I pick I
I got to get at least three options okay
and then I'll choose from the three so I
started watching i r I was like oh I
watch I watch Robocop so I watch a
trailer I was like okay maybe then I
watch Commando I watch a trailer I was
like okay maybe and then I watched like
krer versus krer like a sad one and then
I put on a lethal weapon and then I was
like what am I doing I can't pick and I
I swear to God I just watched about 27
trailers and I went to bed that's crazy
well I I think that's but it was getting
taste I was like I remember that scene
oh I remember that yeah that's great
that's I remember this movie yeah that's
that's enough that's enough I mean the
reason why I get to rewatch I swear to
God it was like I think it was 26
trailers and then I was like I have to
go to bed what was your favorite trailer
of the night well Apple TV does this
weird thing though where in old movies
or like in older movies that they don't
have trailers they just play a clip of a
scene yeah they play two minutes of it
and so I watched Big Trouble in Little
China and I like rewatched it yeah did
you swear to God on the road uh a year
ago well I will say I was like I'll
watch this I these is old school like
cult movies like John Carpenter like
Kurt Russell and I I was like I I watch
it and I was like it wasn't a good clip
no and I was like oh that was the first
one I watched It's not a good movie no
no I mean it's it's we love it you have
Infinity to it but a man gets so mad
that he gets angry he blows up he he
inflates and then explodes yeah it's
like a like a CD like surreal underworld
right so I was like oh this is good I'm
hot like it's old but I just couldn't
and then I I was like went on a little
dive and I went to escape from New York
nice and that I I I almost watched that
did you ever you ever see about
that so uh but then I then I just kept
going and going and going but I think
Escape From New York I was like I should
watch this but then I just kept watching
and watching what else did I watch the
reason why I rewatch a lot of movies now
which is fun because I watch them with
my kids so Milana likes to be scared a
little bit so she was like uh hey she's
like um daddy is there a movie that's
like kind of spooky I won't be scared of
so we watch the original Ghostbusters oh
that's a good call and she absolutely
loved it she got scared of two scenes
she got scared when Slimer comes rushing
I bet and on the rooftop no mind the the
librarian when the librarian that ghoul
she no that was actually that was
actually truly jump so she was like oh
my God so that but everything else she's
great she's like she's super Brave with
stuff so now we're like then I was like
oh we'll watch Gremlins so she would
love Gremlin let me tell you something
have you watch Gremlins lately cuz I
rewatched that [__] are you listening to
what I'm saying I just told you I
watching my
daughter I just told you I watch it and
you ask me watch but but like but like
but like what I meant was before you
watch it this time were you prepared for
what you were going to see because you
kind of remember it CU you watch it
recently cuz when I rewatched it I mean
I know it but when I rewatched it I was
like yo these these these gremlin are
like ripping people's throats out blood
is shooting everywhere straight up Gore
yeah I didn't I didn't realize I always
remember that as a Christmas movie so
she was super scared yeah well I mean
it's happens at Christmas time but she
was super scared of Gremlins and she got
yeah she was like oh she was like that
and then like she was just cing part one
right where where there's a battle in
that kitchen and they microwaving them
and blows up in the kitchen it opens the
door and the eyeballs out and everything
it was some really great effects as I
appreciate it as a filmmaker cuz it was
puppetry right wasn't it puppetry yeah
you know they got that spot and it was
running around stuff I'm surprised they
haven't REM made that uh they did
Gremlins
too they sequel it that I haven't seen
in a long time and that one's even more
Bonkers yeah but they bang a girl and
girl Gremlin that right there's like a
yeah there's a girl Gremlin gang bang
that that guy he walks into they're like
all sorts of all cracked out they get
into the cocaine you don't remember that
yeah but are they is it actual like you
see you don't see
penetration you don't show graphic
penetration no there's no
M you don't get a full
mwai uh um no but they they they show it
simulated or you it's inferred it's kind
of inferred but there is a part like it
kind of in the back they just run on a
train on oh they just run a train on the
female yeah yeah maybe I will watch that
later no I mean like it's hard I mean
because it's like like I I got to see
that not that it's just like it's crazy
it's double bed cuz I can't get
wet or eat or eat after midnight so it's
terrible inside breaks all the rules
bright light bright
light so happy I'm here damn I never
made those
connections um so so Gremlin did you
watch it or you didn't watch it we did
watch again she got a little bit more
scared with that which I wasn't
expecting where's that dude now I
thought he was going to be a big star oh
the Billy Billy zabka what's his name no
Billy no that's a guy from that's the
guy from zaye is the other guy uh he
he's he I think he's around I think he
now dead tragically right what no I made
that up there he
is oh wow he looks great he does look
wow he looks really good I mean he looks
great yeah he's done a couple things so
what is he doing now I got to get my
glasses um secrets of the mwai oh wow we
did a is that a is that an episodic a TV
series Gremlin secrets of the magai I
guess it like a documentary oh no it's a
animated hell fun oh they turn that
you're not see any graphic sex in that
no you're not well it depends depends
depends who made it
um yeah hey don't you dare skip this
okay this weekend September 8th I'm at
the Syracuse Funny Bone for the weekend
and then I'm rounding that off in
September going to Bowling Green
Kentucky Cincinnati Ohio and Toledo Ohio
and there's more dates on and on through
December at salcano comedy.com right now
Syracuse I'll see you this coming
weekend also Sal volcano official on
YouTube please subscribe uh once a week
starting in two weeks weeks I'm going to
be giving away a prize every single week
to only the people that are subscribed
to my YouTube I'm pulling the winners
from there it could be anything from a
prop from the show free tickets to see
me autograph posters a set visit and
actually if we get to 500,000
subscribers I will pull a winner out of
those subscribers to go to dinner with
me and Joe G so that's that also if you
haven't got it get shipfaced cruise.com
come on the Impractical jok is and Eric
Andre Cruz in January 2024 we're almost
sold out check that out out everything's
available right now savano comedy.com
and we're making tickets a little more
affordable because I want to reach all
of my audience so if you you know if
you're on a budget check it out this
ticket's for you as well taste buddies
let's talk about the game time app I
have it I love it I use it basically it
is last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed that's all you need to know
it's everything it's Sports it's
concerts it's Broadway it's everything
you like and they have some real cool
features um killer deals on last minute
the tickets uh you can see where the
view is from the stage from where your
seat is uh they send the tickets right
to your phone so you don't have to go
searching through emails for them uh you
know buying tickets should not be
stressful this really makes it easy it's
a couple of clicks I love it forget
planning months in advance they got
tickets the day of the event and the
game time guarantee means you'll always
get the best price if you find tickets
in the same section in a row for Less
game time will credit you
110% of the difference download the game
Time app create an account and use code
taste buds for $20 off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account and redeem code taste buds for
$20 off your first purchase snag the
tickets without the stress with Game
Time download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price guaranteed
September 16th avanal New Jersey
September 21st through the 23rd Toronto
uh September 29th through October 1st
I'll be at skankfest not doing the hour
there but I'll be there and I hope to
see you uh November nber 11th
Philadelphia Pennsylvania theater of the
Living Arts November 17th Pittsburgh PA
November 18th Buffalo New York November
30th Denver Colorado December 1st
Phoenix Arizona December 3rd Salt Lake
City my gosh my gosh my gosh we have so
much going on and this just in October
28th here in New York City at arlans
grocery Sala windfall
first live show in 20 years people who's
joining us well maybe esoteric DJ Chev
larace is going to be joining us who
else is joining us the stumble bumbs who
else is joining us we'll see you in hell
live it's going to be a Halloween bash
more acts are being announced it is an
event an event an event October 28th we
want to see you there and before you
come make sure you cop that new salsa
windfall album artificial birth
available on all streaming platforms now
we hope to see you people and I hope I
also I also hope to see you Joey
roses W you sold you sold me big time
and sandwich place down in the low side
of New York Joey roses Joey roses.com
we're open seven days a week I'll see
you there and that's where the after
parties's happening on October 28th boom
you bought a a replica of a gremlin that
was made from the mold oh wow that they
made from the movie it's like it's like
out to size it was like this big and he
just has it we bought it in Austin you
were not with us I was with you yeah
yeah I remember that remember that one
of the worst beatings I ever got was
with the Spike doll one of the worst
what back in the back in the my mother I
hid you know they had the SP one the
worst beatings you ever got was with
Spike the no my I hid spike in my mom's
C in the cabinet where my mom got the
dishes out for dinner and it scared the
sh she came after me and gave me a good
one but it was very funny cuz I actually
attached it to the door so when she
opened the cabinet door it came outle
out yeah came out and she she yelled
what the [__] screamed and I was dying
laughing and she came and beat the hell
out of me it was very funny I have a
gizmo doll I have a gizmo doll I
probably still have I have a small bag
it's in a bin in my mom's house that has
like my top like 12 dolls stuffed
animals growing up I still have my wind
to the Poo yeah yeah when I had from
three years old I have like uh two or
three that I was born with wow yeah I
need to get the came out with give them
to
the it's a boy and a teddy bear I got
like a like I think it's like a bear
like a not doesn't look like a
traditional teddy bear but it's like
either a bear or like a a monkey or I
don't know in a train conductor's outfit
oh yeah is it like is it like a what's
his name uh Curious
George No no no okay but it's okay it
doesn't have to be I'll be all right
dude do you know that like I I'm trying
to replace like what up to what year but
I recently thought about this but when I
was young younger I was so scared of
things so I I I watched Nightmare on Elm
Street right someone had the VHS in my
dad's house we shouldn't have put it on
we did I don't recall if he was there or
not but I think we had an older cousin
there and it was on and I watched it and
I was like what year did uh nightmare El
stre come what the [__] what is that
1981 Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey a
Winnie the Pooh horror movie are they
allowed to do that it's been like a
hundred years or something so now you
could do whatever you want with one of
the Poo no way no way no way no way no
way no way no way no way tell me right
now that win the Pooh is royaltyfree
image likeness everything the whole
story that's no way and now there's a
Winnie the Pooh when when did this come
out it dropped like six months ago no
did you see it no no I don't know did
you see the trailer yeah is it good I
don't want to demonetize you could watch
you could watch it
tonight sounds like I put it on the list
Trail
list that looks really creepy does yeah
wow well that means we could use him in
any capacity you want one as well yeah
okay okay oh that's fantastic three it's
got three% on Rotten Tomatoes I mean I
don't know what you were thinking of
course it did yeah but 3% I mean it's
called it's called wi the blood I can we
can we Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey
has has moments but there aren't enough
to make up for the weak plot uneven
acting and general lack of Real Horror
or humor wow that's a tough dig from I
mean I would watch it just to watch it
but I don't if we'll be able to play it
on the Pod all right yeah um so after
that I was I was like intensely
intensely scared and um I would have to
sleep with me and my sister uh slept in
bunk beds and I would have to beg my mom
to keep the hall light on and the door
open outside so the whole light would
stay on and then me and my sister had
this thing that we would
say when one of us was scared and I was
more scared so I was 8 when this came
out when I saw this uh or maybe a little
later cuz it came out on VHS and I and I
we used to say this thing so when we we
would go to bed I'd kiss my Mom good
night and she and she would go inside
and then I'd say like Dana she'd sleep
underneath me I was on top and she said
yeah and I go will you answer me and
what that meant was throughout the
entire night even if one of us was
sleeping or she was sleeping or if I was
sleeping and we got scared it would be
fine to wake the other person up if we
were scared oh that's sweet yeah and so
she said will you answer me yeah and she
said will you answer me and I said I
would say yeah and we go to sleep but my
sister is such a sometimes she back then
she could really be she wanted to be and
um when when when she was you know
pissed off or like we fought during the
day and she was holding it at the end of
the night my mom would leave I go will
you answer me and then she' just be like
nope yeah and I'd be like are you
kidding me you're not going to answer me
and she'd be like no and then like for
real though then I was scared so I used
to sleep with my stucked animals for you
know always a comfort thing but like I
slep with like like 10 or more of them
and I wouldn't want to be exposed
so I had this whole system where I would
lay down and then I would lay the dolls
like almost like in size order like in a
pyramid and then I would like pull the
covers over me and put my arms over them
and hold them and then stay
100% under the covers nothing exposed
like tucked in like a burrito because I
was so scared of being exposed and him
like just slic off a leg a monster can't
get through a confident and as a I'm
sure I did major long-term damage
because I had no I swear to you I'm not
exaggerating there was no ventilation
and I was just breathing in my own CO2
all night for like a year and I would
wake up in the morning and my bed was
soaking wet and my everything was
soaking wet from sweat and I just stayed
the course the whole night all the time
wow from Freddy Krueger Krueger did it
you know what's amazing too isn't
Krueger in the movie likes eight minutes
no swear to God yeah you know that
sanity the amount of screen time him and
Darth vad are tied for the most least
amount of screen time with biggest
impact way yeah like like like I think
Darth Vader was as Darth Vader in the
movies too was in seven minutes the
minute is an hour and 52 an hour and 52
minutes and he's in it 7 minutes isn't
that insane he's doing a quick math yeah
that means 1 hour and four so that means
uh you know an hour and 12 minutes right
no an hour and 45 minutes right it's an
hour and 53 and he's only in 7 minutes
no an hour yeah but I'm saying I'm going
to do the the I'm going to do the
percentage oh okay so 60 Minutes Plus is
112 minutes so if I take 7 minutes
divided by 112 minutes he's in the movie
6% of the movie is that insane that's
insane is that crazy that's l i mean
talk about talk about making an impact
with a character right seven minutes
well I was traumatized 7even Minutes in
Hell I literally I literally dehydrated
myself and I literally dehydrated myself
and sucked in eight hours of CO2 a night
for one year because of that seven
minutes bad seven minutes yeah I didn't
uh I I doesn't help that he's he's a
child molester and a burn victim no it's
like I I I can get past the killer but
then also I recently rewatch it it
doesn't hold up for me really yeah
Didn't I remember three being everyone's
like one they loved like it was a
wheelchair in there something there's
like a a team of people fighting him a
girl in the wheelchair am I making that
up it was like no I think you was
thinking about big trou little chod
three was like it was called like
episode three like the Knight oh he
isn't a or something oh no yeah of
course yes yes yes yes I remember that
the wizard guy yes he goes in and they
all they all become super characters he
could walk in his dreams right CU he
can't in real life I remember that one
that was a good one I was so scared man
that's the Harry Potter origin story but
he's in that a lot longer look at that
poster scroll up a little p look at that
yeah it's creepy now you think she could
handle that Milana no she wants to watch
it she loves Pennywise so I re-watched
the original it because I wanted to
watch it do you have nine hours to watch
it see it I i' only got through half of
it but there's the one scene she's like
begging me Daddy can we see can I watch
can we watch it so I said all right I'll
let you watch the one scene where he
appears in the sewer the first time we
see him yeah and it's the old Pennywise
the old school one she's used to the new
one what's his name it's uh he's
unbelievable clue uh what's his name the
guy who played Penny wise in the
original uh Rocky Hara oh it's him isn't
it is it not yeah that guy yeah yeah of
course it is right yeah it's um IMDb who
plays come on I know his name it's a
Home Alone 2 right no is it is it not
Tim Reed wait is it not the guy Tim
Curry there he is it's Tim Curry yeah
Pennywise see he's Pennywise that's
amazing yeah don't you see it in the
face now you know 100% so Milana wanted
to watch that one scene and I tell you
it freaked me out when I saw it and I
didn't want to show it to her and she
was like Dad Dad and I was like you know
what who am I to all right you she she
was you're asking for it if she get
scared she didn't loved it wow she was
like oh and she like it was like that
but she got a little scared about it
when I said that but that scene's not
too bad cuz he doesn't do the the teeth
thing really until the end and I like
stopped it before but but she was and
then she'll go up in a room and I I
showed it in the morning I didn't do it
like good
night that's not good parad good night
yeah we're watching her room on my phone
um you just peeking late at like full
full mask yeah I make sure I have a tan
because I don't want to peek and look
pasty white were you scared at all as a
kid of anything like like that were you
ever scared like to go in the dark or
like a a movie I was scared of uh my dad
used to do this thing with me when I
used to sit down and I started doing
with my kids which was kind of fun where
I would say Dad what would you do if
Dracula came and my dad would be like I
would take him by the teeth and I drag
him out of the house and say get out of
here we don't want you yeah what would
you Franken I came I would take his bolt
and I'd shake his whole head I did that
whole thing and it became like a game to
me so I really wasn't scared of anything
but I do remember seeing the the the be
movie the
stuff and it's a take off of The Blob
and it's a guy it's alien thing comes
down and it goes in your mouth and it
looks like marshmallows that's why I
have a fear of marshmallows oh right um
it's uh and I didn't eat Egg McMuffins
for a year what was the stuff that the
stuff is white and it it's like that
thing that se's coming out of her mouth
like that um so so it was like people
like people would throw up so bad that
like their mouth would rip open like and
it was really gor and I remember seeing
that movie and that movie messed me up
for a while I was afraid I didn't eat
marshmallows I still don't like
marshmallows but I don't know if that's
the reason but uh oh marshmallows are
overrated I battled against them on this
podcast yeah oh you were on the
marshmallow episode I oh I did mention
this that's right I talk about this on
here yeah but he doesn't listen to me
when I
talk you guys you you especially you you
you I mean like are you like heavy into
films like did you go I mean I know that
like you're in this world but I don't
know like I we were like are you like
study films like and stuff like that and
well I grew up with a disabled father so
kind of what we did okay okay that
doesn't seem to be I can't connect that
dot that's all we did broken neck that
was your thing broken neck we just sit
there and watch movies together yeah so
you were watching were you watching
movies above your pay grade when you
were younger yeah a I remember I watched
animal house at like yeah I my parents
had vhs's and they didn't my dad and he
didn't discern didn't police them like I
was allowed to throwing a radio I I I
could I could quote Delirious word for
word the entire thing by the time I was
like 10 that's amazing whatever it was
12 Kentucky Fried Movie yeah yeah that's
my my good our good buddy love that
David Zucker is the writer and director
you know they did airplane Naked Gun
scary movie all those guys they they
they started a a whole that whole genre
they started and I it was like my
favorite our favorite movie and I met
him one time at the Wild West Comedy
Festival we we hit it off and we went
out to dinner with him and his brother
and then we've been friends for like
literally like 10 years now the ni
FaceTime with him three nights ago the
writer of and director of airplane and N
David Zu he on Jokers he did Jokers he
was on he's on he's been on he's been on
four of the cruises now we're having the
fifth one I think he's going on speaking
of have the Impractical Joker's Cruise
January 22nd to the 26th 2024 I'd love
for you to come on it don't point to me
when you say because that be like Joe's
coming no I'd love for you to come on it
you said you you don't think you don't
think you can come for for the week but
uh I would love it but yeah get ship
face cruise.com right now with coting
with Eric Andre and we're about to
announce all the acts we haven't
announced everyone yet and there's some
big ones really yeah yeah I can't say
right now until we announce but uh this
ship is like 75% full already but
there's still tickets so you got some
you got some big hitters coming you got
some fun things yeah yeah and we I can't
say that either okay all right coming up
there's a lot of you're going to want to
get the ticket I think taste buddies
let's talk about prize picks prize picks
is the largest independently owned daily
fantasy sports platform in America
uh this is what they say they are the
easiest and most exciting way to play
daily fantasy sports it's just you
against the numbers instead of battling
thousands of other players including
pros and sharks you pick more uh more
than or less than on two to six player
stat projections and watch the winnings
roll in it's cool it's different it's
Unique I like playing it because it is
absolutely so simple um quick
withdrawals easy gameplay enormous
selection of players and Stat types are
what makes prize picks the number one
daily fantasy sports app it really is
fun it's some of the most fun I've ever
had doing fantasy sports I've been doing
fantasy sports for 26 years but I've
never done it this way um you can win up
to 25 times uh the money this football
season you just select two more players
pick more or less on their projected
stats and you place your entry and
that's literally it they offer weekly
promotions that can lead to Big payouts
like taco Tuesday um and prize pick now
offers Apple pay for quick and easy
deposit into your own account this
football
season uh like I said I love it
and uh I only I my busy schedule the
only thing I do now is I can only keep
up with football and so apps like these
um actually enhance my football
experience every weekend uh go to
prize.com tastebuds and use code
tastebuds for a first deposit matchup to
$100 okay go to prize.com tastebuds and
use code tastebuds for your first
deposit match up to
$0000 daily fantasy sports Made Easy
that is prize picks
hello fresh America's number one meal
kit what is it you know what it is if
you don't come on you get your farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes deliver right to your
door you don't go to the grocery store
you count on hellofresh to make the home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it is America's number one meal kit
uh guys I love it we use it basically I
get the best ingredients and the best
proteins shipped to my door with recipes
and it is it is right there in front of
you if you like to cook but don't have
the time to go grocery shopping if
you're trying to learn how to cook if
you want to have an experience with your
family and cook together it's fun it's
different every time it comes it's a
it's it's something new you also expand
your own Arsenal about what you can and
can't make okay they have new meals
every single season they have a new fall
lineup of delicious dinners to choose
from you can pick from 40 weekly recipes
that suit your lifestyle from Veggie to
familyfriendly to fit and
wholesome uh when you get hellofresh you
know you're getting the top not topnotch
produce since it it travels from the
farm to your door in less than 7 days
and it is more than just dinners if you
want they have easy breakfasts they have
quick lunches and fresh snacks um
basically I I feel like I never ever
learned how to cook when I was younger
and since hellofresh has been sponsoring
us I cook a meal once in a while and I
just feel like a king when I do it yes
King go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds and use C code tastebuds 50
for 5050 50% off plus 15% off for the
next 2 months okay go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds 5 and then use the code
tastebuds 5 to get 50% off and then in
addition 15% off the next two months
hell fresh America's number one meal kit
sure you guys should do an airplane type
movie I would love to man we did we did
a lot of short films like sketchy short
films we
very much inspired the best the best
premise ever and I I'll I will live and
die by this blind cops where s and I
were two blind cops and it was it's one
of the best two sketch we had a
three-part sketch series we didn't have
a a chance to do the third one but we
did two of them the president yeah the
president's daughter gets kidnapped and
we we get in charge of the case and we
are just these you think we're going to
be bumbling idiots but there's so much
really smart humor written in it like we
walk into the closet to leave and the
and the Q plays the sergeant he's like
you guys are in the closet and we come
out and we're like we know we're just
getting coats and we're in full coats
and leave we keep like bucking the like
yeah so we have we have we have the
third episode written we just never
filmed it we bring back we well
sochowski and who Dutch Dutch I was
Dutch right we we started uh doing
improv in like 99 or whatever and then
by 2006 we started just doing sketches
and filming them throwing up on YouTube
and Myspace at the time and they got
went viral and so Myspace had these
comedy accounts that they would rank
Comedians and we had our account it went
viral and we we ended up being the
number one Comics out of 30 2000 you
remember who number two was uh was it it
was it David Spade David Spade yeah it
was big Comics it no because they had
but we were like one of the only sketch
troops on there but it went and then and
it was weird always joke like David
Spade was like who the [__] are these
tendal no the top 10 was like literally
like it was like Carlos back then it was
like Carlos it was like all the biggest
and so everyone was like who who are
these people like all the comics got to
know us that way and so we filmed these
sketches and we put them up and we
filmed like 30 of them yeah it was
insane but uh yeah and we stayed on at
number one for like like a long time and
we got an agent because of that no [__]
yeah I actually was thinking about you
guys the other night cuz I I'm into the
prank YouTubers these young kids who go
viral yeah they're all doing your bits
it's kind of weird you guys influenced
like a whole generation except except
they're going to do one of our 5,000
bits and they're on that one they're
going to get five billion views yeah and
then I've been on I've been I've been
doing it for 12 years and and 10 seasons
and uh that's my old YouTube channel is
that it's just me doing them yeah is it
like is it a direct rip you think or
some of them are I seen some inspired by
no definitely inspired by they rip off
you guys in jackass more a a lot of them
actually shout us shout us out though
too there's a couple there's a couple
big accounts that shout us out as an
inspiration and a couple of them in the
intros will say you know we do you know
we're doing thing like this and in the
comments you'll see they'll reply to
people like the Jokers did this like we
know we're huge fans like you'll see
that a lot too which I don't mind which
is cool but a lot of it just comes
across more mean-spirited cuz
the era of the thief you know yeah
there's a new a new show uh impr
practical joker show in Australia I
think now yeah they just started I think
it's called like INSP it's called
something in practical jokers and
apparently uh it it started aing a
couple weeks ago and it's a hit oh yeah
so that's good yeah well I'm going there
yeah so okay
yeah better I don't want to show up I'm
touring there I don't want to show
you're on tour right now right I'm on
tour right now so we got to get into
this battle in a moment yeah so this is
it the the inspired employed Joker and
practical jokers and that's a real show
and apparently it did really well when
we when we first licensed it um out we
were playing like 30 countries um but
like 15 countries had their own cast and
like we were dubbed in like the other 15
eventually they all failed yeah there
was a couple of reboots in in England
couple got a couple seasons in couple
Seas but then eventually they all went
away and then they just started dubbing
us and and playing us out there but this
is the first one in a very long time to
it's not even a style compl ripoff it's
my it's the the rip off but inspired by
but that's me running with my nipples
cut out in a t-shirt he just came from
an interview yeah so that's what so they
would they would watch our stuff and and
ask us and and then they redo some stuff
I don't know it never really feels like
it's you know exactly the same but I
wish those guys well but what was I
getting at uh I was asking if you
watching so I'm on tour yeah well you're
on tour I was getting into you because I
wanted to know like what like what older
movies like really inspired you that
like you know what what filmmakers and
stuff like cuz you said John Carpenter
you love him yeah cassavetes you ever
get into the cassavetes OR I mean no
that that name doesn't ring a bell okay
okay um I don't know I'm more just
comedy okay like straight com dirty
work's my favorite movie ever made yeah
fun I'm just a strange comedy my one bad
opinion is I just can't stand Woody
Allen okay I think his movie I think
people live on live on one side of the
other with that well you mean because
the controversy or the movies no the
movies movies the movies annoy yeah I
think I think the hits are hits and the
misses could be misses you know um but
uh what was I gonna say I got my ADHD
kicking in right now I couldn't I can't
tell should get to the battle yeah we'll
get to the battle you're on tour so
you're on tour they can get tickets at
Jo official.com I'll go to my Instagram
the links in the bio there and you're
going to I mean right now you have many
I started right now yeah I'm got I'm
doing 40 dates to the end of the year
and then uh and then we'll continue a
little bit in next year and then uh so
what what what day is this coming out in
Monday Monday which is what
day oh yeah I start Chicago yeah so it's
Monday is September September 4th is
Monday that's when this drops so in uh
four in four days yep September 7 sorry
three days sept in Thursday Thursday
night September 7th three nights from
now you're playing I start Chicago I do
Chicago mil Milwaukee and Royal Oak
right and you're going to playing the
Vic in Chicago kick off the full tour
it's a big big show yes so that's in
three days from right now and I don't
want to give anything away don't give
anything away okay but you might have a
special guest I might okay do you know
him I might know the special guest
that's going to be at the Vic this
Thursday night September 7th for your
show in Chicago I might know him
coincidentally the person that might be
there y on the 7th in three days from
now yeah uh is filming their standup
comedy special there it's a great
theater it's a great idea in December oh
wow and the tickets for those shows yeah
go on sale the 13th of September in a
few days pre-sale for two days and then
on September 15th they go fully on sale
wow and that's going to also be at the
Vic and that's happening you know in 10
days from now you get those tickets so
there's some Synergy there for whoever's
going to be there for whoever's going to
whoever's going to show up we have no
idea to sell fast and you you you're
pretty much near you got to get tickets
right now if they want to see you for
sure I mean it's only three days three
days from now what are you doing get off
your ass and get yeah we filmed this a
little earlier so it may be sold out but
if not get it because there will be
surprises yes there'll be lots of
surprises but the battle we're doing
today is um and I'm going everywhere too
so not just yeah you have 40 cities so
check it out me too I just kicked off
right now leading right up to the
special in December I'm me I'm doing
like you know 20 cities I think Salan
comedy.com just took away all the
mystery what he said he said the person
that might be there is filming their
special in December and then you said
yeah I'm filming my special in December
I didn't say where you're right they can
draw any conclusions they want
100% the battle today you came in today
we didn't really know what it was we
were texting on the way in about foods
and whatnot and and uh we didn't land
somewhere and like right before we
started I was heating up eggs and I said
what about like uh cuz I looked and I
said I I have one here sleep naked
versus sleep clothed and I looked up and
we were like of course yeah because you
historically famously sleep naked and I
sleep not only clothed but I like to
sleep in a proper top and bottom
matching outfit of pajama so it's polar
opposite it is 100% so the battle today
is sleeping naked or clothed you're
taking naked I'm taking clothed and it
is time
to TT l e buds very good yes I was with
you I watch no matter what happens I
love you mhm no matter what happens I
love you no you you yell at each other
don't don't you compliment each other
too uh I don't know when we do it no
matter what happens I love you do we no
we don't that's all we I just give you
compliment I love you you're one of the
funniest guys I know I love you you are
you are the funniest guy I know yeah I
love you too so we know that's there
okay um what where we at with time just
so I know how much I could really get
into this right now
minut okay we're good okay here's
why
it's time to get you like putting
clothes on before you go to bed what are
you
dumb no I here for me I I I'll tell you
one of the main decid factors for me and
this is different for me and you and I
know this is why you could sleep clothed
is because you don't sweat like I sweat
big thing for me is I got to have as
much air flow come into this body as I
can you've known me since 1990 yeah I
sweat like a sun like I sweat like now
when you sleep you go into a polo State
no no I don't I could sleep I sweat is
if the conditions aren't correct right
or I'll tell you another thing that
happens some you put the air on too high
you bury yourself under the blanket
because it's too cold and you sweating
under the blankets cuz it's too cold
yeah I mean's a fine line I just I I
wake up feeling uh
constricted um you know you get you get
like a hard neck you turn the wrong way
for what like for when you roll over I
roll over to do with closed and
nonclosed because if you don't have a
shirt on you can't get choked by it you
idiot that's what I'm telling you you're
getting choked out by your own shirts
while you sleep I'm getting attacked by
my I'm getting I'm getting attacked by
my
clothing just just just just come to
terms with it go up one size I can I'm
already at the
max no so I can never get down with
sleeping naked ever it feels unnatural
it feels too vulnerable it feels like
I'm then disrespecting my bed and making
my sheets the underwear it feels like
what's happening to you you're you're on
the carriage door the I don't like
everything free form I don't like free
form I I I like to feel secure in Every
Which Way even my whole body there's
there's a weighted blanket Market that
exists for a reason cuz not only do
people like the blanket they like to to
feel pressure on them that someone
laying on top of you that's for lonely
sad people they can't find somebody to
share their bed with them and just like
let me get the feeling of a human the
body pillow the whole Market is for
lonely dumb people that sleep with
clothes
on well I do sleep with pillows I sleep
with five pillows you have a body pillow
I I don't have a body pillow but I have
a king size that I let go through my
legs up through my arms but it's like
it's I made you're straight monkey in it
you're fire in it yeah you know how we
do right I do one between the legs one
between the arms one here one over the
head and one behind me in the back but
do you have do you have underwear on too
when you think I wear when you're sleep
you think I go free bowling in the
pajamas yeah no why so you have double
layer on the cotel you have a a double
layer you mean like humans do every day
in the world everywhere no right double
layer no so you have a pair of on Murray
wears no underwear a lot Murray wears no
underwear a lot by choice his life why
you pulling him into this well because
he should be
shamed he's a command he often wears no
underwear we don't know why we don't
know why it's disgusting and then we
know it so like then there's like one
less layer between us and and his stupid
gray
penis he does he has a mouse gray penis
I never saw it Q saw it one time said it
was gray like an
elephant I he we laugh about it Murray
knows he has a great penis maybe it
doesn't have it anymore I don't know
what
from where to pajamas I don't know if
his penis is having a bad day or what
happened but uh but he he walks around
naked and he has no no right he's
disgusting as it is and then also he's
not like like renz o llamas he's James
Murray like why are you putting on your
dungar with nothing on underneath that's
scratchy too yeah God forbid the zipper
the flip side of the zipper is still a
zi that's why it's gray yeah the now if
you I I can't get on board with sleeping
in underwear don't you feel do you toss
in turn
yeah of course okay so then you don't
get wrapped up in your own [__] no I
don't wear a straight jacket to bed no
yeah I'm just saying I wear a beautiful
to me matching how's your underwear
right now my underwear is nice I Second
Skin by Tommy John on and send me free
stuff I'm going to say it do you do you
adjust yourself uh your underwear often
when you're out and about in your day
when like when you have to no because uh
not really cuz I I got I found an
underwear that really works for me my
question really is like what what about
your hog yeah when you're in bed and
you're flipping and flopping you don't
get all like that's what wakes me up if
I have to wear pants if I'm forced
to if I have to and I end up like this
and I have this right now do you know
what's going on in that area because I
sleep like this this is how I'll sleep
sometimes I'll throw my leg up I also
have 47 dogs in my bed well that's well
that's another reason that's a strike
against nudity you got 47 dogs in there
anything from a nip to a scratch to a
lick you don't want I mean I would put
on two pairs of pajamas would you if
there's a if there's a roaming lick not
joking it's not this opportunity of a
roaming lick you're putting players on
dude do you live in life wrong wait wait
wait so you have like 20s something dogs
but seven or nine sleep in the bed with
you right there's eight Gatt pups and in
the sanctuary there's 37 dogs right so
he has he he has started a nonprofit
organization for adopting pets GS and he
runs it out of out of yeah the GATT pups
and Friends runs out of the runs out of
the home we also have a a storefront
adoption center in town but the dogs
live in part of the home and there's
eight dogs that we are are the ghetto
pups not the friends and you sleep in B
they're all like do you've seen it
you've seen it yeah but so you're not
even scared that like no I mean the dogs
they're not going to go They're not
going after anything yeah but what if
uh again Nails teeth if they no if they
doing a jump on I mean I have a comfort
I have a I have a nice comforter you
know that that covers you you know I'm
not stand under the covers okay well
that's not nice you get to
I talk Pas scottian in the morning
sometimes we snuggle at so so with with
the
nudity I also just feel like you're
exposing your privates which is fine who
you bed and the bed should be like you
don't owe your bed anything yeah you owe
your bed to be your sanctuary and to be
nice and crisp and neat and clean cool
and yeah you you know you have I mean
what's I mean literally there two fresh
there's nothing better than fresh sheets
and p i with that I love a good fresh
sheet pillowcase but you know there's
also laundry you could just wash your
shoes no I know but like I don't know
also don't you feel more secure
comfortable snuggled warm whatever with
with a nice comfortable pajamas like
comfy pants like I have flannel ones I
have silk ones I I have the ones that
are just like very like they almost feel
so soft that you can't even like you
know what I mean it feels like you're
not wearing pants they feel
good so you're trying to encapsulate the
feeling that I get by taking my pants
off well like I said I'm wearing these
things right now right called Second
Skin cuz it's so comfortable sponsor you
almost don't feel it Tommy John if
you're watching we know that you are and
by the way is Tommy John the name of the
guy who owns it invented it why this
called two two brothers Tommy and John
oh really no oh um they don't advertise
with us when they should because I
exclusively wear their underwear for the
last like four or five years no joke I
have like 50 pairs tomm if you're
watching this Tommy John I I know you
have Kevin Hart as a spokesperson at one
point but call me that's his name Thomas
John Patterson no no no that's is owned
by fellow a fellow named Thomas John
patters Thomas John wait but why is
there a picture of the pitcher cuz he
also a pcture famous pacher named Tommy
John oh Tommy John is not related to
Tommy John okay but he wears their
underwear he was laid off from his sales
job okay well and the idea is it's
called Second Skin because it's so
comfortable you don't realize you have
it but you still get the benefits of it
I get that I get that but you're
spending money what about rolling on a I
don't know rolling on an exposed bow
what about it happens but it's the risk
you run I don't know it's it's
unflattering well I will say this okay
now talk to me about this if you are if
this good bad naked and this
gooded yes 100% but who are you trying
to impress while you sleep well no the
tooth
Fair let me see no the person sleeping
next to me or just myself just a general
sense of talk to me about the person
coming next to you would you what is
this what about if there a fire oh okay
that's a leap that's a leap he pulls up
an article that says New York City house
fire kills five including three children
and I was like oh my God what is this
and he's like well in case it's a what
do you do what you're under I at the
photo I at the photo do you think I'm
the first person I was like I mean that
happened oh yeah what if there is a fire
I already you could have done it better
but you know now I'm thinking about this
poor family but
whatever no no but like yeah you got to
run out what about that I got a
hose you can't run out the middle what
if you hear you run the midd what if you
hear something downstairs what if you
hear something downstairs in the middle
of the night like you got to get I sleep
with eight dogs you think I'm worried
about it I just open the door in the
polling nonetheless if they hear
something that means something's already
there then you have to take the time to
go in the drawer on no no it's on my
nightstand ready to go because I also
have children that come in if they have
a nightmare I have to put what about
your children coming in if my if my kids
come in I have to slip them on
underneath the kelvis so then your kid
walks in yeah Remo or Milana walk in and
you
go and they see you reach for your
trunks pull them under the thing and
then they see you go like this and then
they know I they know I sleep naking but
what is that what is that what do they
think that is they don't know just sleep
naked you don't think you don't think my
8-year-old daughter knows what naked
means no no no no no no what do you not
know how of people sleep like you their
dad an adult sleeping nude two weeks ago
she asked me if she could sleep naked
she learned about watching you she asked
me and I said I said no you're too young
to sleep why you have you have comfor
why she too young because that's a good
point yeah come on let's get let's now
you got exposed now I got a great Point
here literally INF figuratively uh no I
I just because you know if there's a
house
fire you know I mean if a dog jums on it
and scratches why can she not sleep
naked well I just felt like she didn't
understand why I slept naked this is
what I'm saying you don't she sees you
that's confusing yeah well I think it's
just it comes down to comfort you want
to be your most does your wife sleep
naked uh no she sleeps in a in a comfy
uh Ensemble right so how does she so
what's the D Dynamic there does she just
like she does she ever does she like it
not like it no opinion no opinion no
opinion oh she might we've never spoken
about it
I never sat it down and said we had our
problems in the past but it never was
honey talk to me about me
sleeping so do you do you then get in
bed take the endar off and put it on the
side oh no I come I prance to the bed
yeah you walk around You' been around me
I'm baby I'm proud of this I don't love
walking around nude it just feels oddly
vulnerable it just feels weird that like
just being exposed any anywhere Mark
Norman came on he said that he's never
ever walked backwards naked uh walked
out of room naked in front of his wife
ever or anyone because he doesn't want
people looking at his ass or his ass
hole oh really yes okay well that's
seems like he and I was like okay I kind
of get what you mean like he said he
specifically said his whole but like I
was like I don't know how she's going to
see that but but uh but you know what I
mean it's quite it's quite like weird
like kind of thing to it well the thing
for me is like after you do feel
liberating let's talk about after you
make love okay okay you have somebody in
bed with you and you you're snuggled up
it's like nice it was such a beautiful
moment you guys had together and you're
laying there do you be like let me just
get dressed before I go to bed or do you
fall asleep no no I get dressed so
you've never just fallen asleep after uh
I mean in my life I don't know but as a
practice I would probably you don't know
you were there you know I mean it's life
is long and I I know life's long I've
beted Millions I know there's been
Millions you've beted but I'm saying out
of the million like no actually I think
about my comfort and I'm like oh I want
to feel comfortable again I I put my
clothes back on I feel comfort with them
on like comfortable okay so like I might
I might not have jumped out and done it
but like eventually too I don't like
that either no you if I'm clothed it
doesn't matter if the other person is
because I have the clothing so when I'm
if I'm near them I still don't feel but
if they're not clothed I mean skin on
skin is good to a point but if I'm
trying to sleep all night and it's like
hot and it's like skin on SK skin oh no
skin on skin is the number one thing for
human interaction everyone knows that
that's for a baby and a parent but we're
all babies and parents no anybody you
can't get more intimate hugging hugging
bonding we just finished the in this
scenario we just finished having sex I
got to now feel like I got to rub skin
yeah you're welcome did so thank you nah
no I think it's I that's different
though what I'm saying is really if you
just want to be comfortable and not feel
like you just have to wake up and go to
work because that's all it is pajamas
are clothes don't have to put a name on
them you sleep in clothes yeah right
that's it you sleep in clothes I don't
sleep in clothes because my day is over
I'm done with the clothes part of my day
it's time to have some fun but why is it
what what is it that makes you feel
comfortable without and me with you
really just feel strangled by your your
by your clothing I think I realize why
Joe D Roa gets so mad at
you because you don't really listen
that's crazy you should be on my side
100% you know he's not I'm I I I do th%
don't get it twisted but what am I do
I'm making good points right now if he
was here see how we're making logical
points and having a conversation if he
was here it wouldn't have went that way
no that's for sure yeah that's for sure
I do so why will you frustrate with me
in this moment and I'm willing to change
I'm persisting no because yeah because
you also persist to effect like you've
done the show too long with Joe where
you can't have a normal conversation
without letting people talk and take in
their information as well as you
normally do please continue to speak
okay so what I would say is when Point
what's par what's Paramount during sleep
Comfort yeah right am I more comfortable
naked yes are you not yeah and that's
okay I understand and that's okay but
what I'm trying to get to is why why do
we feel comfort in that way differently
CU I feel like a mmy I feel like a mummy
you feel liberated Tangled yeah I feel
like starfishing it and Things fall
where they may I don't want to have
clothes on to go to sleep okay and I
will say there are some benefits and
there are some not of being dressed the
house fire we spoke of you're ready to
go I I might get burnt throwing on a
comfy an intruder who knows an intruder
he's going to see my balls I'm still
going to fight him doesn't matter that
doesn't matter it's always in my house
not supposed to be there when be like
don't look isn't it odd that people feel
more vulnerable fighting nude yeah
because maybe they feel like they might
especially men they might get kicked
there but honestly if you had on a light
pair of pajamas yeah you have com
there's no Extra Protection but yet for
sure people feel like they're at a dis
Advantage if they're fighting cuz people
could grab it I think okay but they can
still grab it if he had you don't get as
good a grip okay right okay especially
have like a pant on like these that are
slidy
yeah CH you ever see a nude fight I did
in college you did I did tell tell me
about it I did uh I was well I had a I
had a fra brother named Mungo this big
animal guy who slept naked okay and
somebody who uh in the hallway like
these drunk guys were in the hallway
whatever and he came out I mean that is
and he and he came out naked confidence
I will never have I will never walk out
of a room into a hallway full of people
yelling to fight them new it was college
and he walked out and he was like go to
bed I Got A tes and the kid was the kid
was like d man we and he just went up to
him and he put him up against the wall
and he was like and he started like when
he's full-blown naked in the hallway he
was just banging him against the wall oh
so it wasn't like a fight no no I didn't
see like so that's even worse for that
other person he's getting Man by handled
by a large naked youve seen a nude fight
yeah so I was on a keg party in
douglason on a golf course and this guy
was streaking who slept with somebody
else's girlfriend and then the boyfriend
was there and ran at him mid streak and
it was a fist fight fighting naked it's
an advantage it's a disadvantage no it's
an advantage can't hold anything he
destroyed him yeah he can't grab
anything can't grab a shirt can't throw
him around can't manhandle him so the
guy who was streaking and that was the
[__] in the situation end up
unfortunately beating someone destroyed
that kid he called the cops the cops
pulled on the golf course and I had to
hide in the sand trap till like 4:00
a.m. who called the cops the kid who
lost the fight to the naked man no and
that's how that kid is known now the guy
that lost the fight to the naked also
known as Fred yeah also the fact that he
cheated on his man I feel I feel for
that other guy what you gonna do now was
the other guy gonna win no matter what
or did it have something to do with the
nudity and not he was also everyone was
cheering him streaking he was just
coming off a high he was already
adrenaline rushing yeah he was up he's
amped up and this guy must have been
like I'm going to fight also I don't
know if I would have fought that guy
nude that's PA the right like why not
just be like I'm going to get that guy
when he gets his clothes on like why go
atam nude maybe he thought he was
vulnerable but then also you're going to
be swinging well he's right there we
were all drinking but he didn't the guy
didn't decide to just grab his balls
like a vice I think you're worried about
the fist coming at you yeah but the fist
don't mean nothing if you get B you got
to hold it them balls you got to hand
the balls you got to have quick ball
grip yeah but I mean that's the first
thing I would go to you're going right
for the balls in a fight have you been
in a fight if you're fighting a naked
man if you're fighting a naked man
you're going right been in a fight I'm
going right for the ball no but I see
what your point I think I think I think
if you're going if you if the
opportunity presents itself I someone's
pounding on
me% I'm start using like a punching bag
yeah you think I'm not going to be like
ah this all I can
do by the way after he won the fight
continued to
streak wow dude was a champion that's a
champion that's a man Fred is a man of
Life swear to God I'm more empathizing
with the other guy it feels like a
traumatic experience if it helps they
were all on pills too they were they
weren't great that helps do you know
what [__] did at the end too he naked s
on a guy's face now you're joking around
I swear he banged him against the wall
and the kid was over and he threw him on
the floor and everybody he saw everybody
watch him [__] started showboating and
he just gave he gave him one of these
all right so we'll learning right now
you do not fight a a nude a nude person
you do not they're an advantage of
because without the clothing like you
have nothing to grab you can't I mean
you're mid-fight you're getting served
by the naked guy you just start
stripping to out just like both of us it
turns into like a dance B
but did you ever see two nude people
fight that's got to be a spectacle that
probably
happens yeah but I wasn't
there they fight now nude and Greece no
in ancient gree s but you said they
still do it it probably happens in like
Singapore and no I really mean it yeah
yeah like Oh you mean like some SE
undergr underground yeah Thailand oh why
naked why
not this is I don't this is all right
well
look there's a reason that there is a
market for pajamas 100% yeah uh forever
that I mean you mean night clothes the
second pajamas could have been people
slept naked not by choice that's right
okay got textiles people made a gown and
they started sleeping in gowns well I
mean people made clothes because you
know that's it you came embarrassed by
your own body yeah you know listen I
don't know who's going to win this cuz I
could see all those people that sleep
naked ride or dying for it for sure you
so the pajamas were first introduced in
Britain in the 17th century originally
known as mogul's breaches yes breaches
really and they also be spelled that way
you see that with the py yeah I saw that
py jamas okay do you have uh next guest
contact info okay can can you want to
check to see if um all right let's go to
the phones pimpy let's go to the phones
this was fun this was good it does say
it's healthier to sleep naked here it
does and I'm clearly healthier than
while it is limited research on the
health effects of sleeping naked some
studies suggest potential benefits
sleeping n can help you your core
temperature cool faster yeah promote
better sleep and potentially improve
vaginal health and male fertility that's
if you're wearing tidy whes two kids
yeah I don't have sleep apnea yeah and I
sweat last when we sleep I think I
win who would have thought I'm healthier
than
you um we're going to the phones here
let's see what we say what if a fire
breaks out or a burger breaks in there
you go people who sleep naked don't care
about emergencies okay that seems to be
the theme I already know D Roa is
picking sleeping naked you're wrong s
with AAR and have to get out you're
right uh I used to sleep naked until I
got dogs yeah uh they stopped so I
didn't chew off my snage I can't wait to
hear the results of this one I don't
need to have all my bits out about with
the cats people are really laying on
laying in on this fire thing like if
there's a fire why can't you go out
naked well time is of the essence yeah
for sure you know you're not going
to yeah I'm not going to go out naked
most practical is sleeping cloth but
sleeping naked gives you the best sleep
cuz there's nothing constricting W
they're hitting on all the points see I
told you uh half naked and always with a
sheet or blanket okay I sleep in a
T-shirt and undies I can't have anything
like PJs around depends on what state of
sobriety naked for sure I toss in turn
all night sleep t-shirt wake up in a
choke hold I thought that was BS
everyone's saying I'm telling you it's a
thing I've never heard of that uh only
bad thing about sleeping naked is when
the cat okay it seems like everybody in
your corner is about the fires how many
you know f is are happening I feel itchy
when I'm naked I I I agree with that too
I feel itchy when I'm naked like you
know itchy yeah like I feel itchy when
I'm clothed yeah uh I sleep naked cuz I
love it however I had to stop doing it
we had a house fire and I was outside
standing in seven inches of snow and all
my
glory there you go you're also supposed
to sleep with shoes under your bed I'm
surprised how do sleep with on
why sometimes I sleep with a slip a shoe
on no no why why well my grandfather was
a firefighter and it's like same exact
thing just get in and get out uh all
right naked with some fresh sheets while
the air is blowing I mean Naked and
Afraid is a thing so when I have
nightmares I'm ready want brand so it
seems it seems I don't know I don't know
where this is going I think more people
probably sleep clothes so I think I have
the advantage but uh Humble Pie segment
here pimpy drum roll let's see this
percentage right here pimpy all right
okay oh all right it's there a few
thousand votes uh sleep Cloe does take
the W yeah
64.2% to
35.8% yeah I mean that's not that far
big of a difference I I I I thought most
people didn't really I think I think the
fear of fire really won the day I think
the fear of night fires really really
sway America because that seem to be
every comment what if there's a fire
what if there's a fire yeah yeah yeah so
has anything I said today sway you and
like when do you ever sleep with pants
and what would be that scenario when my
kids get scared and they have sleep in
bed with us or um if it's by request all
right
uh well that was great uh anything else
to plug we know you plugged the tour I
know you plugged the pups and I know you
plugged the uh iHeart the new pod yeah
um anything else we missed just our
friendship buddy I love you yes your
show this Thursday night September 7th
at the Vic yeah with special guest
special guest will be coming and then of
course joat official.com all my tour
dates and tickets and then listen to our
podcast me and Steve Burn do uh two Cool
Moms um and you could find that anywhere
you listen to podcasts and we had a very
special guest that the new ones will
drop while they'll drop it'll be after
this it'll be in October in about a
month yeah about it was a great that was
so much fun love how uh the winner
always says to the loser I still love
you babe and you would say I love you
too I love you too I already told you
that
beforehand taste bu they com to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools going
to fight but only one food 10 be right
tast spuds man yeah they coming to the